rich is starting us off this hour in
California hi rich welcome to the Dave
Ramsey Shire oh hi Dave I appreciate
your wisdom thank you
I'm calling my wife and I are mulling
around how to be more helpful or
encouraging to our adult daughter and
her husband the issue is this we are in
a good financial place and they are not
and the issue is that when we look at
our will and our estate planning since
she'll be our only beneficiary we'd like
to get some help with how to persuade
cajole or otherwise boost them into
accepting some kind of financial
planning advice they are good smart
people and we don't have any major
attentions with them but we brought this
thing up and they're kind of a soft
cuddle way before and they my daughter
kind of defers to her husband on this
and he's kind of a good but kind of
stubborn guy and when we look at the
amount of assets they will get dumped
into their labs lies when we pass on we
wish we could have more of a say in sort
of how they manage that down the road
you know short of putting us some kind
of B know how much how much money would
you leave them when you're died well if
my wife and I died today they would
probably get between our assets and an
insurance somewhere in the neighborhood
of three million or more okay and
basically what you're saying is is they
don't do bad they just really are kind
of disorganized lackadaisical and they
really need to get their act together
they are living pretty much paycheck to
paycheck is just his paycheck and it
also has child support you know
obligations to his first wife that will
go on for at least another eight years
so let me give you a pro let me give you
a proposed idea for you and your wife to
consider leaving someone that
fuses to handle money well a big pile of
money will ruin their life right so I
would not leave them the money unless
they agree to become responsible because
you're going to give them harm
I mean you've written have you've read
the stories about the lotto winners who
end up in divorce court the lotto
winners who end up you know ruining
their lot the money ruins their lives it
doesn't it's not a blessing when you get
money and you don't know how to handle
it it's not a blessing it's a curse
well we're with you on that and so you
would be harming your own daughter to
leave her this money in this current
situation and so that's the way I would
approach the conversation and just say
okay number one you guys are adults and
you get to do what you want to do we're
not control freaks we're not over here
trying to tell you how to live your life
but we have a problem
our problem is we have three million
dollars and we would like to leave that
to you all however in your current state
we know that that would bring you harm
rather than be a blessing and we love
you too much to give you harm so the
only way we would feel good about
leaving you this money is if you were
handling money well so that this money
is a blessing to you we refuse to harm
you because we love you too much and so
if we if you guys want to keep doing
what you're doing you have that right as
adults we're not going to interfere in
your life but you need to know we're
going to leave the money to a charity if
you want to get on board and learn how
to handle money so that this money is
then a blessing to you and to our
grandkids and whatever else then we can
show you a little bit how to do that
again we're not trying to control your
life but we refuse to bring harm to
people that we love that's an insane way
to frame it we hadn't gone down that
road but I I get it yeah so you're going
to go through Financial Peace University
you're gonna meet with a financial
planner or you're out of the will that's
the cold message I would not deliver it
that way yeah no we have the financial
planner we've been working with
twenty years and you know if they would
agree to meet with him you know well I
mean they need to go through a basic
financial class like FPU because they
can't to make a budget oh yeah well you
know I'm with you on that they feel like
they're just you know I know what they
feel like but you and I know while they
feel doesn't matter they're in helped
they're incompetent right yeah so their
feelings don't really matter in this
discussion so in my house we would add
another way of framing it or an
additional layer to the framing and as a
matter of fact it is how we've handled
it at our house and that is as people of
faith as Christians we say it's not our
money it's God's money we have to manage
it and as a good manager I can't leave
it to a bad manager well that's who
we've kind of toured with that Chris our
son-in-law Ashley and our daughter they
met as attorneys and he in the sense
over that time has he still got some
warning but he's been our pastor so I
think that stewardship idea exactly then
you've got that you've got that lens to
discuss this through and so you know and
basically my will my trusts are set up
with our grown kids now that if they're
going to be living a life of misbehavior
they are not no longer in the will
automatically or even after I die
they'll lose their ownership in Ramsey
if they start aside they're going to
snort cocaine and live on the back of a
yacht we're not trying to raise reality
TV stars yeah is there another Avenue
about having some I mean there's nobody
in the family we think we should take
this on but having some kind of a
trustee or financial person of some hon
like a bank person I am some of the
problem is and the trustee is under
constant pressure by these people who
are irresponsible to give them money and
he's going to be continuously now and
really what's going to happen is every
time they go to the trustee and the
trustee says know you're still there
respond
they're gonna be mad at their dead
father all over again
yeah I'd rather get the mad over with
one time no right right
and you know you know nobody knows the
future but my wife and I have no reason
to think our mortality is gonna end
tomorrow but there's no guarantees so we
are trying to think ahead here yeah and
the good news is is that you know you do
have leverage if you're going to give
someone money you have the right to
speak into that or choose not to give
them money and they're not entitled to
this legally morally or spiritually
they're not entitled to this money it's
not their money it's yours and God has
given it to you to manage and manage
well and giving it to someone who's
irresponsible is by definition not
managing it well from a stewardship
perspective and so that's the way our
kids are taught misbehave or be
irresponsible or be lazy we're not
giving it to you
it's not ours anyway we're managing it
forgotten not gonna let you mishandle it
for God that's you know just because you
put a fish on the back of it don't mean
you can drive it this is the thing man
you gotta have some sense about stuff
it's aggravate and it's hard to do but
good luck with that I hope you can work
that through without hurting everybody's
feelings it's necessary though